okay so I this is about a joint project
very recent with roughly and big Lipton
and it has their very ambitious up
tightly using the uncertainty principle
to end malware so hopefully I convince
you that we can keep the promise in the
next couple of minutes okay so the
problem will be looking is Mallory
injection what is Mallory injection we
have a system that's running some
software we have an attacker that is
trying to inject some malicious offer in
the system right management software
malicious software one it starts
executing can do all sorts of bad thing
it can take control of the system right
it's data on an untrusted server
everything and we want to see how we can
protect such a system actually you know
your computers and smartphones do have
mechanisms that protect against and
systems the standard mechanisms our
antivirus firewalls and security patches
and they work don't work you can decide
whether this is the case but what I can
for sure say is that for them to be
effective they need to know the virus so
first the virus needs to be analyzed
then we can protect against it and that
has a big issue which is that the virus
might stay on the system for way too
long and do damage slowly which was for
example the case with the target attack
last year so those are not the only
suggested approaches there are more kind
of research oriented or experimental
approaches that have been suggested in
the security applied security research
so these are roughly so I'm sure I'm
forgetting something but the most in my
opinion prominent then most related with
our work our software diversification
here the idea is that we kind of
randomized the binary of the software so
that when the virus attacks he will
introduce an inconsistency and that will
provoke a system failure another one is
analyzing the logs and looking for
patterns that could be that would not be
in the normal program execution and the
one which is probably closer to what we
do is so call the station i will say a
few more words about it in the following
what I wanted to say here is that
although those are more research
oriented
they do have some intuitive security
guarantees but usually the assumptions
are either not that will be fine or too
strong and they don't have a security
proof because it's not it's not a custom
there to do security proofs so the
closest thing to a security proof is
finding all possible attacks that I can
ensure that my system resist these
attacks and then I ran it on my computer
and you know it indeed works and it
seems that to be I cannot a packet and
to make it more everything that my
system secure I run it to other
computers and I cannot attack it there
either but that's the closest thing I'm
a bit unfair with it so let me just put
things a bit more in perspective from
our side so I would say that the mode of
operation in applied security is I give
you a system that works and it has it
sounds of being secure our mode of
operation is I give you a new very cool
idea which is secure and it has a chance
of working at some point yes yes that
and that's what so we're going to try to
kind of going to try to live here with
security but i think that at the end you
see we live somewhere here and we will
shift towards there slowly ok so bit
more concretely now a bit more
theoretical what we attack model this is
the assume that this is the system
memory that we have those are let's say
like binary words and the virus is
another binary consisting of let's say
five words here and it goes and sits on
the memory and when some of the location
execute then the virus kicks in and does
all sort of nasty things so our goal is
to try to detect such an injection yeah
we don't try to protect against it we
won't solve it but we will try to detect
it and we won't care what the viruses
going to know what the viruses so how
can we do that surprisingly our idea is
inspired from quantum physics and
particular from tons anyone here does
anyone know who that is how many people
were in the boot camp okay yeah this is
vern hasn't bird
and he has his famous uncertainty
principle which very very freely
interpreted says that when we observe a
quantum system we inevitably sends it
state so along the same lines the
principal we're going to be using is
that when the attacker in the X malware
on the system he never double its NC
State and we're going to use exactly
this fact to catch him so on a very very
very very important variable high level
here's what we do so don't ask me for
details here i'm going to give details
in the following i want to give you the
general idea for approach assume that
this is the entire system memory and
assume that we have a software that we
want to secure but it's running it's
running the system it cannot be attacked
so we can detect that packs so what we
do is we take a secret key and we split
it we secrets Eric you know Susan crypto
in many pieces and then we blend the
actual software that we want to protect
with the pieces of the secret key and
write it in the memory
now when the virus attacks using sit
somewhere in the memory and how are we
going to catch him by periodically
clearing the system with a query which
depends on the secret he needs the
entire secret key for answering and the
system will not be able to do so because
the virus we have sat on some
information which is relevant for the
answer MC we have tons of questions just
wait 10 minutes for asking because okay
so one question I can already answer is
that of course this assumes that the
virus does not know the secret key or
the search of the key because otherwise
it's you know it's very simply to
isolate you just know everything in you
reply I will answer the rest of the
questions hopefully through the talk if
not please ask me when I give more dps
in the construction now I would like to
say something about related literature
there ya go on there is the system that
checks the shares so it's a beautiful
application of secret cherry this system
that check the shares is awesome under
make may also that's it that's an
excellent question and a great idea this
is one so any question organizer is
excellent so so okay so a few words
about related literature okay the
problem is huge right so everyone
understands it and although we include
we haven't looked at it too much
insecurity there's tons of work so I
could spend the entire top you know just
giving related literature instead I
chose to do what they do you know at the
end of the movies and give credits like
this if you did not see your paper cited
here let me know and i will discuss
without giving citations because again i
would have to fill the entire slide the
most related in this security literature
line of work which is the so-called
attestation once at a station we can
think of it as a challenge response
protocol between an interrogator which
mean we would call the very
fire and the system that we try to
verify or interrogate for integrity to
see it has not been attacked and in a
seller's response relevant at sahlen's
you know corresponds to a something
saying 10 to the system show me that you
haven't been attacked and the response
is evidence that this is the case right
there are roughly three types of at the
station completely software based
hardware aided and what is called remote
at the station which I consider
something between the shorter and
hardware and I'm going to give you some
general overview of how software based
at the station works to see the type of
assumptions that one would need to do
for it okay we have the verifier in the
system what happens is that at a time T
let's say the verifier sends to the
system some textual computing function
this would typically be a hash function
and a code of evaluating on his memory
and the seed and then the system is
acting let's say this is the condoms of
the memory of the system the system is
expected to compute this hash function
iteratively accessing random memory
location and doing so many times that he
with high probability traverses the
entire memory and he produces that
section of the entire memory which he
sends to the verifier and let's say that
the verify receives is at time T Prime
so now that the verifier does is first
he does everything by himself so he
knows the exact state of that system
here she does everything this will not
be the case in our system anyway he does
everything by himself checks find a
computed section and check that it's the
same as the one he received and the
other thing that he does is he takes
that the time it took for the system to
reply is the time that the system is
supposed to take when it has not been
infected by malware so what's the
advantage of this approach no secrets
right no kiss no nothing I can really do
it on software
there is a lot of drawbacks which
hopefully you're already wondering about
from my previous point which is I really
need to know the exact configuration the
configuration the system is to be
extremely simply and I need to know the
exact configuration so that even if the
malware just does a swap operation while
computing that section I observe a
detectable slow down furthermore
although there are no secrets there
needs to be a security under the system
right because if someone can get that
section and bypass the security tell you
can just do the computation by himself
the state is public another assumption
is that the attacker cannot have
external head again this would violate
kind of the timing you could just take
the section send it to a much much much
faster server to the computation and
then return the outcome in time then the
network delay needs to be predictable so
if there is an unpredictable overhead
that the network might take while
transmitting at section when I cannot
really use the value of the time to say
that the virus was there another
negative i will go to this one in the
lacs to this one another negative is
that the actual section code needs to be
minimal so this means that there should
not be any way of computing the function
that I gave the system to compute faster
than the program i chose that's that i
don't know any way of proving such a
statement but again the difference is
that there is a system which has been
shown to work under these assumptions
under these assumptions it's not just
it's not only the assumptions on the
speed its assumption song than no leads
of the speed that's the where it gets a
little bit less realistic if it would be
just about the spirit that make sense
but knowing exactly how much time it
takes for a system I mean there's no way
you can know that for a laptop and that
would be my point here so that this
model of what the station can be cannot
be used to target from any more location
for example
Jeanette and cannot be used in target
complex systems so you can kind of
interrogate your mouse where you're
physically next to it so the network has
almost zero latency and it's a very
simple circuit you can interrogate you
know your fancy you know what are
Caitlyn if you have a network to it you
know and you want to see whether it's
been infected by malware yes yeah always
but it seems relatively hopeless to
interrogate like smartphones laptops or
even like a computer that sits on your
basement for ten years it's probably too
complicated for that furthermore another
disadvantage is that the verifier needs
to work as much as the actual system
right I need to compute the section
message which is something that we
encrypt on know that or believe that
it's not a good idea okay so this is for
software the station very quickly what
is hard weather station yes absolutely
are we assuming that during the normal
execution the memory doesn't change at
all yes and we're showing even more we
are showing that I know exactly the
contents of the memory there verifier
nose and not be they so this is yeah the
verifier working with an offline
absolutely yam if you know your talents
and you know the code so you can do the
flight but you need to do it and you
need to do it for every challenge right
because it's the silences to be random
otherwise once you have uncertain the
adversary can upset again so you need to
do it every time you interrogate what
does offline mean like between two
interrogations is it offline or online
yeah that you could do it
so at the station can be done also in
Hardware not surprising what we mean by
her brother station is that we pretty
much have a trusted party on the on the
on board that does the work for us so
this means that the system has an
onboard secure coprocessor exit which
sees it keeps private keys it cannot be
tampered with and it does complicated
crypto compute signatures and computes
Hasse's it does whatever you know it's
our dream ideal functionality so you
know whether such 3 my direction else
exists in practice there are several
advantage which we can discuss if you
want but one of them would be that this
would need to keep long-term keys what
happens if the key leaks there's also a
quick hmm criticizing the entire field
of crystal why wait now as I said that I
mean you came up here there are some
sort of long-term kiss is crucial right
because in crypto you could in principle
update your key here you shouldn't
update your key because if you do then
you create an attack surface you know if
you are a pack o if you update very
often then the device will just attack
this process right so you should rely on
something in there which is the case in
modern like modern modern tpms like
really put a key in there and they
almost never updated some technical
stuff yeah yeah but they're there i plan
to me I planned I have a lot of
technical stuff in there but unless you
see what's done I don't think that
you'll be able to appreciate you know
why this thing there won't be obfuscated
or non Mallaby codes or you know newsx
or snack there won't be such things it
will be really really simply crypto so I
don't know whether you know the
technical is so it will be very very
very simply technical staff so the goal
here is really to make something that
works so I need to compare with things
at work and I assume that I didn't know
when I started this project nation that
people here don't really know how these
things at work
work okay so remove the station can be
thought of as a hybrid between hardware
and software Assessors its kind of
hardware a hardware the station with
very very minimal hardware Samson so I
just have a you know private storage
maybe some read-only memory and most of
the requirements are push through the
architecture most of the scheme still
need this mean code minimality
assumption but I think this is the most
realistic mode of at the station still
it's as far as an only pehle kabhi to a
very very small systems like embedded
systems stuff that i showed before like
a mouse maybe more than what you can the
advantage of both those approaches is
that you can actually do them remotely
right there are keys you have private
storage so you can do remote the station
okay getting to stuff that they're
generally like more there has been also
encrypt or works that would in principle
try to address that's a problem one
which is between crypto security like
ours is the proof source of secure a
sure but the idea is that I sent to the
system acid and I expect the system to
fill up the entire memory with
pseudo-random noise so it over right
everything and show me the random notion
that i can know that it did so this is
kind of two evasive but it does give us
what is called and security root of
trust so it does give us something which
we know doesn't have malware but we know
that has you know garbage so tree how
much we want that and it's it's actually
a very slow as a process you can imagine
there are proof of it variability there
the incentives are very very similar
right when I'm trying to to if you want
interrogate a system to prove to me that
my data has not been have not been
altered the main disadvantage here is
that it's it's pretty good when I try to
do that on data i'm gonna try to a lot
of computation which needs to update
that's not good because first of all I
need the verifier and the other in the
system to be online and even more in its
in its update and it something like I
think the best that we can get is a poly
log computation so that's not acceptable
for
our purposes of course there's program
of Education right i'm pretty sure i
don't know whether it's been solved if
it's not been some time salaam it you
know we solve it in the next couple of
weeks later the prob i'm sure that the
problem can be solved with program
ification it's like it seems like a very
which is a prototypical application for
the same reasons as the diversification
you know the thing that you're trying to
attack makes no sense so it's very
unlikely you will attack it in there is
no but i don't know i believe that it
can be done I haven't looked at it I
just put it there because I don't know
whether it's been done already so
finally very recently in this year
speakeasy there was a paper about Tampa
resilient and liquids resilient
architecture which is even closer to
what we're trying to do the reason there
is that the goats are really really
ambitious so trying to have both these
things makes it essential to use really
more fancy cryptographic primitives like
Malibu codes and you restrict the clash
of attacks and that's again not
something that we want okay so bottom
line there are works but they don't seem
that they could come in practice anytime
soon Laurie attacked by virus you find
this is basically the last rule no no
wait what do you mean when you have
limited attacks like like in the last
row will split stay and that's what
happens here yeah of course yeah no I
mean the general principle is that
absolutely but but you know you have
arguably it's not clear whether those
attacks are all you want to protect
against okay and likely have some time
to go into our results okay so what we
provide is a modern definition for virus
detection schemes and then an
instantiation with the following
properties so we almost did no
architectural assumption are slow down
factor when the program executes is very
very small a very small cost that it can
be done even smaller by some hardware
modification we make of course no timing
assumption so we can interrogate over
the
internet we don't need to know the
configuration of the system and so on we
don't need secure storage our system can
secure dynamically updated binaries so
with no cost no interaction the verifier
does really really really work
essentially it's just one encryption and
checking for the product for inequality
oh ok MC is and he has only public
information so no secret key search
between their very fire in the system ok
that's it those are all the properties
ok and how do we do that so we're going
to use the random action maximizing Modi
like the model word you know the CPU
just has the instructions in the
registers and even the program edits
data is stored on the RAM so in this
program will refer to random access
memory not random access machine so I
just make a big move occasion ok so we
will assume that the ROM executors
usually better than execute cyclists it
gets mid-cycle it gets a word from the
memory it puts it on their heads to the
CPU and then performs operation and
potentially write something at the
memory and this is a without have the
reality assumption we assume that the
word size is a order of the security
parameter if this makes sense in modern
architectures we have 128-bit words you
want to nate is a pretty reasonably good
parameter but we can actually we don't
need this assumption ok so here's what I
virus detection scheme is it consists of
five algorithms key generation that you
know generates a computational
verification key compilation which takes
the software we want to secure and the
computation key and generates a secured
version and then a talent response
protocol so it's alan's algorithm that
takes test the verification key and
output the talents a response that takes
the software that we secured or actually
whatever it's been computed on it and
the talents and outputs the response
that's what the system will use another
verification which is a predicate that
says you know ever the system's been
attacked or not and the security
is defined via this game so this this is
described as a game between an adversary
and a challenger so the first step is to
compile the software using the
compilation k into a secured version
which we then right into the memory then
the software the the Machine execute the
system execute and at some point the
virus injects the attacker in sex it's
virus and before or after this happens
and multiple times we can do the
challenge response protocol where the
verifier that other said can be a very
lightweight device generates the talents
the system produced a response on the
verifier text using the replication
period hapa 0 or 1 depending on if the
virus there or not so so does this model
cover the case for example where the
software no no so if you get a pop-up
which asks you whether you would like to
install a virus and you click yes we
don't protect one in Sofia and so it
downloads of idiot idiot has viruses now
that's what I mean yeah I wanted the
pop-up will not ask you so no no no
it'sit's like buffer overflows its type
of injections that you don't approve
implicitly or explicitly but it can be
combined with like you know other
approaches that protect against that's
like you will need certificates there
right you could check the signature they
think you're downloading and stuff you
could combine the system with that one
we haven't done it at least not yet so
so the sets of VDS is secure if it has
the following properties say this is
kind of a completeness property
compilation correctness which says that
the software which has been compiled
computes the same thing as the original
software verification correctness which
says that if there has not been an
injection then I will not catch one and
soundness which is that if there has
been an injection of malware I will cut
it with a real improbability ok and now
how do we do it again
so we will go in two steps first we will
you describe a simple scheme I have some
time right first I will describe a
simple scheme which does not need any
architectural extra architectural
assumptions but it only protects against
a smaller clash of attacks like I will
say what is that this class is and then
i will show how to make it better to
protect against any injection even if
the the virus knows exactly the
locations where I would put the kissers
even if he is arbitrary small for that
we will need some extra architecture
like some microphone piece or something
so for the simple scheme the key
generation algorithm is the public key
encryption key generation Agra so the
compilation k is the secret key the
verification kiss the public key now for
the compilation I'm going to use an
additive secret sharing very very simple
tools very fastball it what nervous
about selling is it just splits a key in
many shares that sum up to the key the
very nice privacy purpose that it has if
someone has all the kissers he can
recover the key but even a cig did sir
missing information threateningly hides
the key furthermore if you have a right
any T beats of any of the cells you're
effectively losing p bits of the key
this is actual operation ok so and how
we're going to use it let's assume that
this is our entire system memory and
this is this the entire world apart from
the cpu registers that's the only member
that the system has what's an
obstruction of coordinate and assume
that it has like two n words and i want
to compile a three words software in
there so what I'm doing is first I'm
writing these words where I live an
active empty word between any two of
those and whatever free space it is I
keep doing that but put and no ops so
that you know this will be kind of
working space for the system when it
tries to computer it would be data in
there or anything okay so next I take my
secret key I computer sharing let's say
this is the sharing and when I
interleave shares of the key between
every two words so finally what I do is
of course if that if that software here
execute then it won't complete the same
thing that has the original right
because it needs to go from now if this
offer will go from execution will go
from w1 w2 this thing is to the same
thing so I'm making sure that this is
the case by adding appropriate jumps and
making sure that I remap the
instructions that points to memory
locations to point to the correct number
location I of course cannot do that for
an arbitrary binary but we saw that we
can do it for a complete glass of
binaries which is it includes many
things and it's not like the sequential
so it's roughly any non self-modifying
binary and you know if I have the source
code I can compile it anyway in such a
binary and then compile the secured
Russian if I don't you know it's an open
question how wide this glass can go ok
so what the challenge response again
this is the memory the talent is like I
choose a random element then I computer
encryption of it using the verification
key the response i record struct so the
system does that why did we construct
the the secret key and then decrypt the
challenge sends to the verifier who just
takes that it equals with the original
random message it shows so a kind of
buggy version and informal version lore
everything that allows me to make a
wrong claim is that if the injection
over rights two consecutive work then
it's caught with high probability and
you know the proof of the buggy version
that you know if you have a right two
consecutive words and you inevitably
overwrite the kisser which means that
you destroy the key ok so so something
which I did not discuss is of course
that I want the system to be able to
reply to the to the challenge right so
this means that the system itself so the
code that is running should have the
response coordinates so before I even
start compiling what I do is I add the
response code and then I compile the
entire thing so this way I
also the response code what properties
do i get from that as I said it's a very
simple version and no architectural
assumptions the performance I mean we do
pay kind of that's a very bad
overestimate but you know if two are the
keys in between and the jumps you pay
three times the space we don't really
pay three times space because most of
the jumps are already there you can have
a word which has instruction and its
sound but you know this is a bad or
estimate but we don't really care that
much about what we care is time those
spaces like math super commodity
nowadays and in terms of time the snow
down comes only from the actual exam so
when the system execute it ignores
completely the case it jumps over the
keys and the only slow down is for this
jumps when the system is interrogated
then it means to traverse the entire
memory and it needs to and but you know
when it traverses don't do anything
fancy right this does a mixture of their
words that it reads and then it does a
singly a decryption so this thing will
take a lot of time a lot of minutes but
you have the guarantee that you will be
able to cut any injection in a minute or
in 10 minutes versus not being able to
catch it and you won't have any slowdown
in your execution so we believe it's
better than state-of-the-art which is in
fact not cutting it ok and the
verifications I said just you know just
random message and encrypts in sexual
equality so that's all it does so I
still haven't answered completely motifs
question and I'm going to do that now
the reason why I said that the theorem
was buggy in formal to informal but bag
is because of what is known as a time of
check time-of-use attack and this is
exactly what happens if i attack the
verification right so in other words i
have my i have my program which is
secured it's executing and while it's
executing you know it hasn't been
attacked yet it's a lance cumson what
does the system do it starts
reconstructing to construct the secret
key and now it's about to
torrid start decrypting so I sure that
at that point exactly the virus attacks
again II went and bought this thing like
of the cell for that wow wow okay so
assume that now you know while it's
executing it has the key here we go
start of the memory now the virus
attacks right I am attacking this
process that's a disaster he just sits
anywhere he wants does anything he wants
with the system and just just use the
kilodays on the cpu any way to reply it
replies any future attempt how do we
solve that we used two keepers sk1 BK
one st to begin to in tandem what i mean
by that is that we essentially
interleave the sharing so we put first
word first serve the first key seconds
first of the second to second board the
solar support and then the talent is a
double encryption first to encrypt with
PK to then we read the PK one and that's
the chalice and we expect the system to
delete both how first it reconstructs
the second key it's the story in the
first game it strips of this encryption
when it erases the data where this first
us toward then it will distract the
second key strips of the second
encryption replies so then now non buggy
but still in formal version of the
theorem is that if the injection of the
rights to consecutive words then it's
court code with high probability at the
latest in the next verification why you
know if it overrides again towards what
is going to was what if we have to do is
clean one of it 21 shares of the two key
one of the search of the two keys right
and either this key has already been
reconstructed so that does not affect it
in the current of the station but it
will be coding the next one or it hasn't
been usually when we cast him on the
spot actually by just using a two
passage of the memory we can catch him
on the spot without waiting for the next
of this i won't i won't discuss exactly
that happy to discuss it because i was
interested okay so a lot of time okay so
very quickly how can we kind of improve
that to allow the virus to know exactly
where the keys are stored and you know
install this small couple of bits
everywhere so instead of spreading we
spread by one word more then we put our
secret keys as before in tandem and we
also in this world that is there we put
a special Mac which consists of two
hashing of the keys and then a
multiplication and addition and to take
advantage of the map we assume that the
architecture itself has a slight is
slightly stronger so instead of just
taking one word at a time it takes for
words first sex the mac and if the mac
verifies it goes on in process the world
otherwise this overrides the part of the
strength and you know this is any formal
theorem which is that any injection I
will because this high probability the
idea is that the magnetic proof
guarantee that you know if I override
small parts of the key I will be able to
guess the mac i will be caught just buy
the mac tech if I override large part of
the key I will be caught by the other
station because I'm missing a large part
of the key of course here i need the
encryption scheme that is used to be
liquid resilient because i'm not
rewriting everything so that was very
fast sorry ok so the properties that we
have i won't go through so the slowdown
is essentially that jumps in the mac and
the mac could be potentially done in
hardware hopefully we we do it soon so
just the point here is that modern CPUs
already do these operations that we need
for the mac and very efficiently like i
feel that vision free multiplication
hashing that's all we need and the
verification is roughly the same but the
encryption algorithm is heavier ok so
concluding this is this the beginning so
there are electrons of questions i'm
sure that you have even more one is you
know of course we are very wasteful in
terms of memory we would like to be able
to compile more programs this way
how can we design this abuse oh that it
really slow to minimize the slow down
from this extra mac instruction the big
question is this is a very simplified
version so how can we extend it by
having secondary storage and you extends
there and of course you know the obvious
next day with simulations
implementations and benchmarking and
with that I want to thank you and thank
Google for not being very ok I didn't
understand how this accommodates nurses
and inject themselves on the stack so we
agree as we take the memoir includes
everything so what I what I have does
this vector of the i'm sure this memory
includes the stack sea creatures as is
now it can so it's not it doesn't fit
that simplification for now but the next
step is to try to extend this this is a
very simplified model right have a
unified mera stack these programs you
have states about what just general what
happens with the state some of the
memories of use for the program yeah
they read the green parts of the memory
are for the program only they're not
touched by the other station so that you
can think so the stack is supposed to be
on these green parts of the memory yeah
everything all the useful memory that
are going to be that are going to be
having the w's yeah whatever the w's are
this is the the where the programs this
is like then we'll be catching because
of the mac the previous word can you
update the second attribute the back
yeah
hey what there's like a lot of things
optimizations that I can and should be
played there yet over to questions and
one answer okay one it's a memory before
he injects a seasonal oblivious to he
doesn't get to see the keys or the key
share with you but he knows he can even
choose the software to be combined and
he knows the exact compiler so the
compiler doesn't use anything about it
so have another question in no answer
okay